in this video we'll talk about glutamate
glutamine cycle glutamate is an amino
acid which can also serve as a
neurotransmitter glutamate is an
excitatory neurotransmitter in the brain
in fact 60 to 70 percent of all the
synapses are actually glutamatergic
synapses so it's pretty common in the
brain
glutametergic synapses can be found in
the central nervous system and also in
the peripheral nervous system
now let us talk about the glutamate
biosynthesis and the utilization so
actually glutamate glutamine cycle is
under this broad theme
so this is the synapse so it's kind of
like a tripartite synapse you have a
prison apps post synapse and you have
astrocytes which are glial cells
regulating this synaptic activity
so in the prison apps when the action
potential reaches the terminal glutamate
would be released in the synaptic lift
which would eventually bind to the
glutamate receptors in the post synapse
important part is how glutamized is
synthesized in the synapse and packaged
so glutamate in the synapse is
synthesized from glutamine by the help
of enzyme glutaminase
one synthesize it gets packaged into the
vesicles
now glutamine comes from the glia the
astrocytes so there are specific
transport Porters in the prison apps
which uptakes glutamine and that is
utilized in the prison apps to generate
glutamate
now glutamate is ultimately
packaged in the vesicles with the help
of v-glute transporters
now when there is an excess amount of
glutamate in the synaptic cleft then it
can be uptaken by the glia with the help
of excitatory amino acid Transporters
some amount of excitatory amino acid
Transporters are also present in the
prison apps so once glutamate is
upticken in the glial cell in the
astrocytes it can be converted into
glutamine
by the help of the enzyme glutamine
synthetase
and this glutamine as I have mentioned
can be channeled into the prison apps
which would be utilized to generate
glutamate
and this is one of the system by which
synapse efficiently generate glutamate
from glutamine and this is a rapid
synthesis time efficient synthesis and
by this gliatexan important role in
modulating the synapse synapse and
release of neurotransmitter
now let me tell you that too much of
excitatory drive by glutamate is
actually bad and it leads to run away
excitotoxicity in the brain which
results in neuronal death
so how does astrocyte help excess
glutamate in the synaptic cleft can be
uptaken by the astrocytes and thereby it
can help the system to clear up excess
glutamate and preventing the circuit to
be damaged by too much of excitability
this is how this particular cycle is
really important first of all it's a
fast way of generating glutamate second
of all it is important to maintain the
glutamate balance in the synaptic cleft
I hope this was useful if you like this
video give it a good thumbs up you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram page
links are in the description you can
follow and support our Channel using
super tanks you can pay via paytm PayPal
or UPI see you in next video